[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
hallo und guten abend hinein wenn man
nicht mehr weiter weiß dann gründet man
einen arbeitskreis klingt ein bisschen
abwertend der spruch denn es ist ja
schon was dran in verfahrenen
situationen hilft tatsächlich offen und
ehrlich miteinander zu reden und echte
lösungen für eine historische
herausforderung findet man auch eher
selten allein im büro so gesehen kommt
die klausur das politische
klassentreffen der bundesregierung heute
gerade recht andererseits steigt mit den
preisen auf gas und strom auch der druck
auf die koalition und in der koalition
stimmung und zwischenergebnisse aus
meseberg von christiane hübscher
zwei tage auf schloss meseberg also
sollen helfen mitten in brandenburg
beruhigendes grün überall und die
ampelkoalition liefert nach tagelangem
streit brav die bilder voller harmonie
die olaf scholz am morgen bestellt hat
das wird eine klausurtagung wo es gute
stimmung gibt und die bereitschaft in
einer ernsten lage eng
zusammenzuarbeiten zum wohl des landes
der grüne wirtschaftsminister h weg seit
tagen im feuer wegen
konstruktionsfehlern seiner gas umlage
verkündet vor dem schloss änderungen
anspruchsberechtigt sollen nun nur noch
unternehmen seinen die systemrelevant
für deutschland sind für deren
unternehmensportfolio russisches gas
relevant war die keine boni und
dividenden zahlen und die absolute
transparenz garantieren also alle bücher
offen so dass da nicht gespart werden
kann und wir sind uns sehr sicher dass
wir schon mit diesen maßnahmen dafür
sorge tragen können dass das was die
deutsche öffentlichkeit die letzten vier
fünf tage so aufgewühlt hat dann auch
geklärt wird sie brücken hier auch über
einen dritten entlastungspaket jeder der
drei ampel partner hat dafür eigene
vorschläge gemacht noch diese woche
wollen sie sich ein die kritik der
opposition schon jetzt grundsätzlich die
gasanlage ist handwerklich hamburgs sie
wird auch nicht dadurch besser indem man
ein bisschen an dieser in jeder
stellschraube arbeitet sie muss komplett
überarbeitet werden jede
kabinettsklausur hat ihren stargast
heute war dass spaniens regierungschef
sanchez der preis den meseberg die über
gewinn steuer an das funktioniere gut in
spanien olaf scholz lässt das
unkommentiert denn er weiß mit der fdp
in seiner regierung aktuell nicht
machbar
im heute-journal update nachher fragen
von gundula gause an den chef des
deutschen städtetages was die kommunen
von der bundesregierung jetzt erwarten
egal ob am flughafen von helsinki oder
den stränden sardiniens was in diesem
sommer an vielen orten in europa
plötzlich ganz besonders auffällt sind
russische touristen auf der suche nach
sonne und shopping scheinbar
unbeeindruckt vom krieg den irland gegen
die ukraine führt sollte die eu weiter
visa an sie vergeben oder ein komplettes
einreiseverbot für russen verhängen dass
es keine schwarz weiß frage die europas
außenministerin und minister der heute
auf der tagesordnung haben da hängen
viele weitere fragen dran florian a
wer dieser tage durch die tiefgarage des
flughafens von helsinki schlendert
entdeckt solche autos luxuswagen mit
russischen kennzeichen wohl von russen
die von hier aus dem urlaub in die
eu-staaten und wut auf sich ziehen diese
personen müssen verstehen dass von ihrem
steuergeld an der krieg bezahlt im
wahrsten sinne des wortes die bomben die
in diesem moment ukrainische kinder
töten
außenministertreffen in prag europa
kehrt aus der sommerpause zurück
gespalten finnland lettland estland und
tschechien vergeben bald kaum noch visa
an russische touristen wollen dass
europa mit sieht doch nicht ganz europa
ist davon überzeugt es
ist wichtig zu unterscheiden zwischen
denen die an diesen krieg schuld tragen
allen voran der russische präsident und
seine entourage
die die kriegs anstrengungen
unterstützen und auf der anderen seite
die russischen bürger
frankreich und deutschland wollen ein
abkommen abschaffen dass die visavergabe
seit 2007 erleichterte mehr nicht auch
aus sorge um oppositionelle
dieser bundesregierung ist wichtig sehr
schnell verfolgten menschen in russland
eine ausreise zu ermöglichen
auf leicht strengere regeln zur visa
vergabe wird die runde sich morgen wohl
schnell einigen nur dass dies vielen am
tisch nicht ausreicht schon jetzt
kündigen osteuropäer an den streit
weiter zu tragen auf die nächste ebene
der staats und regierungschefs
so und die nachrichten im überblick hast
auch heute duo anna und da schauen wir
auf die lage in der ukraine konkret im
süden des landes dort hat die
ukrainische armee nach eigenen angaben
gestern eine gegenoffensive in der von
russland besetzten region hessen
gestartet meldet heute erste erfolge so
seien in dem gebiet rund um die stadt
unter anderem mehrere brücken zerstört
worden die für russland wichtig für die
versorgung mit nachschub sein russland
dementiert dagegen die berichte die
inflationsrate in deutschland ist im
august wieder gestiegen und zwar auf
voraussichtlich 7,9 prozent wie das
statistische bundesamt mitteilte das
sind 0,4 prozentpunkte mehr als im juli
und liegt vor allem an den hohen energie
und lebensmittelpreisen volkswirte
machen außerdem wenig hoffnung dass die
verbraucherpreise bald wieder sinken
werden für die kommenden monate erwarten
sie sogar eine zweistellige
inflationsrate grund dafür sind das ende
von tank rabatt und neun euro ticket
sowie der start der gasanlage
die windkraft in der ostsee soll massiv
ausgebaut werden das ist das ergebnis
eines energie gipfels der acht ostsee
staaten der eu darunter auch deutschland
das heute in kopenhagen statt gefunden
hat konkret soll die offshore leistung
des 2030 478 werden ziel ist es sich von
fossilen brennstoffen und damit auch von
russland unabhängig zu machen
die zahl der toten wegen der
verheerenden überschwemmungen in
pakistan hat sich laut regierungsangaben
auf mehr als 1100 erhöht und ein drittel
des landes sei betroffen und die lage
könne sich noch weiter verschärfen denn
die ungewöhnlich heftigen
monsunregenfälle dauern an die
pakistanische regierung und die un haben
angesichts der katastrophalen lage heute
einen ersten gemeinsamen hilfsplan
vorgestellt und rufen zu spenden auf
genauso wie deutsche
hilfsorganisationen wenn sie den
flutopfern helfen wollen können sie das
über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe iban de 65 104 106 100
104 106 100 stichwort zdf nothilfe
pakistan
es klingt wenn man nur die überschrift
liest nach einer fröhlichen kunde so
sonnig war deutschland noch nie im
detail wird klar das ist dann ein
schnitt mit folgen seit über 70 jahren
registriert der deutsche wetterdienst
die sonnenscheindauer bei uns bisheriger
rekord 2003 mit 793 stunden und dann
jetzt dieser sommer fast 800 20 stunden
im juni juli august die experten sagen
auch das dürfte bald ein typischer
sommer sein peter wagner
der rhein nicht nur als wasserstraße von
erheblicher bedeutung hier biebesheim
werden täglich 130 millionen liter
abgepumpt bei extrem niedrig pegel nur
die hälfte und dem wasserwerk aufwendig
gereinigt anschließend versichert es in
solchen gräben füllt die
grundwasserschichten im hessischen ried
wie einen schwamm wieder auf daraus wird
neues trinkwasser ein modell das schule
machen könnte
wir speichern das wasser und das ist
eine möglichkeit die wir zukünftig im
rahmen dieser zunehmende dürren glaube
ich wieder öfter ins gespräch bringen
müssen in großen teilen deutschlands war
der sommer viel zu trocken das saarland
rheinland pfalz und hessen melden eine
historische sommer dürre das macht der
landwirtschaft zu schaffen setzt den
ohnehin geschädigten meldern weiter zu
ein problem das sich seit 2013
dramatisch verschärft dunkel rot bis
violett sind die alarm farben im dürre
monitor des helmholtz zentrums extreme
trockenheit bis zwei meter in den boden
wir hatten wirklich viele extrem erlebt
neue hitzerekorde neudeutschland
sonnenschein rekorde in deutschland in
vielen regionen sogar der trockensten
sommer seit messbeginn also so viele
rekorde in einem sommer habe ich als
metrologie noch nicht erlebt der
heißeste ort liegt übrigens im
vermeintlich kühlen norden hamburg
meldet am 20 juli 40,1 grad celsius
richtig viel regen gab es im
voralpenland 500 liter seit juni
manchmal in extrem kurzer zeit
und jetzt blicken wir auf aktuelle
wetter und da gibt es eine
unwetterwarnung des deutschen
wetterdienstes vor schwerem gewitter mit
heftigem starkregen und hagel in teilen
baden württembergs und so wird das
wetter die nächsten tage morgen ist es
im norden wolkig in schleswig-holstein
oft sonnig im süden gibt es schauer und
gewitter die höchstwerte liegen zwischen
17 und 26 grad der donnerstag wird
größtenteils freundlich am freitag gibt
es dann im südwesten am samstag in der
mitte und im süden schauer und gewitter
mit 18 bis 26 grad bleibt es sommerlich
warm
und das war es vom journal team in aller
kürze jetzt noch viel spaß beim fußball
und bis morgen
[Musik]